hello everyone and welcome to a really
crazy game that just took place in the
uh european uh blitz championship
between young shisht of duda and russian
grand master anton demchenko uh it's a
really really a wild one and as you can
see in the in duda's quote above the
board four queens on the board is such a
crazy game uh now uh that's only part of
why this game is uh so so enjoyable so
let's just dive straight into it and
then we're gonna
we'll discuss it a little bit more so uh
like i said round 14
duda is leading the tournament let's
check it out we have e4 by duda we have
e5 knight to f3 uh knight to c6 and
bishop to b5 so the real opus is on the
board uh a6 morpheus defense bishop to
a4 and the
the modern stein its defense we have c3
uh giving the bishop some retreating
squares also preparing d4 we have bishop
to d7 and now we have castles we have g6
uh black is now ready to maybe think at
his a dark square bishop also later on
he's gonna have a nice support he's
gonna play knight the e7 uh try and bust
open the position with f5 so it's a very
active approach uh uh very fitting for
uh for a blitz game with d4 do the
strikes in the center bishop to g7 and
now again there are a lot of possible
ideas here this is a very well known
position most often uh here is just rook
to e1 uh duda place h3 sort of a sort of
awaiting move also takes away the g4
square from uh from white sp from
black's pieces uh and now we have h6 we
have rook to e1 and now knight g to e7
so you can see uh with all of these
pawns being already advanced and the
knight is ready to support the pawn
being pushed to f5 uh we we still don't
know if black will be castling queen
zero to kingside or is he castling at
all we have bishop to e3 uh and here
again a lot of moves are possible but uh
bishop uh but b6 is a new move so
already as of move 10 we have a
completely new game let's see how dude
approaches this he he plays d5 he grabs
more space in the center and the knight
now has to find a reasonable square so
you could uh bring the knight all the
way to b8 then maybe trade off the
bishops then maybe knight to d7 to c5 or
or you know who knows what but he goes
for knight to a5 instead and now you can
also play maybe knight to b7 knight to
c5 end of the night we'll get back into
the game somehow
we have capture seven queen captures and
now knight f2d2 duda knows that f5 is
coming and he wants to
improve his center with with a move like
f3 so he has to move the knight so here
we have f5 by black f3 and now advancing
the pawn all the way to g4 we have
bishop to f2 and black is not uh
messing around he plays g5 he wants to
play h5 and the g4 and attack dudas king
as do the king already castle king's
side uh demchenko's king is still in the
center of the board we have c4 still
waiting with that b4 move as you know
that can always be a deadly one knight
back to b7 uh and now we have knight to
c3 with h5 preparing g4 and only now we
have b4 by duda
preparing to further expand on the queen
side and also c5 is coming at some point
so here uh you'd think black should
really start um you know the attack with
the g4 but it's not easy for example g4
we're going to play f captures and after
h captures queen captures and the attack
is pretty much over the queen has no
squares all of these squares are taken
so you can play some like maybe queen to
diet but then you lose the bishop uh so
you'd have to trade queens here and
you've just given up a pawn for no well
obvious compensation so instead black
castles king side he still waits with
with the pawn push and now we have
knight to b3 duda prepare c5 even though
c5 is possible right away but this is a
blitz game so we are not going to over
analyze things knight to d8 uh and now
finally c5 so you can see that uh the
center is closed black is attacking on
the king side and since white can't
really play in the center and you don't
want to push on the king side you will
counter attack on the queen side that's
how chess works so rook to b8 and now
even c6 and i'll look at this pawn chain
it's uh it's already becoming quite uh
quite a monster
we have queen to c8 and now king the f1
yes this is duda's plan he now wants to
attack on the king side but before doing
that he wants to shift his king all the
way to the queen side so king f1 we have
knight to f7 king to e2 we have knight
to g6 and now king to d2 we have knight
to h6 black also maneuvering very nicely
he's now ready to bust open the position
with g4 queen to e2 and finally g4 but
duda not reacting to this even though
you could you could let's say trade and
maybe play rook to h1 uh not not a bad
idea just grabbing hold of that h file
but he starts pushing on the queen side
with a4 uh now bishop to f6 black is not
interested in playing a move like g3
even though it's a strong move for black
it's not a move that uh well it pretty
much uh
closes the position and it doesn't
appear that you will be able to do all
that much but both players still have a
pair of knights so at some point you
might be able to sacrifice a knight for
let's say the h3 pawn then maybe the g
pawn
starts marching forward but there's
still too much stuff on the board so
it's impossible to make plans like that
so bishop to f6 and now we have king to
c2
king to f7 and now b5 so asking uh do
you want to open up the position or do
you want to close the queen side as well
so here we have a5 and look at now this
massive pawn chain this is not something
you see very often we can even use the
green color here so uh nothing will get
through this on the queen side or in the
center so now there's only king's side
where we can do something
so knight back to b1 uh and now bishop
to h4 still black can play g3 and
completely close the pawn chain but he
he decides that uh you know if anything
is to happen in this game uh we we have
to start capturing some some pawns so
here h captures on g4 bishop captures an
f2 queen captures and now h captures on
g4 we have rook to h1 and now even if
black closes this at least you've uh
you have your rook on the h file we have
rook to h8 and now knight one to d2 we
have king to g7 uh and now knight to c4
we have g3 finally closing the setup
here queen back to e2 and now knight to
f7 offering a trade of rooks so king to
c3
you can see that duda is already
imagining uh
the the resulting end game he is getting
his king as deep into the position as
possible uh because he wants his king to
be able to support the past pawns uh
once you know stuff gets traded off and
yes i am i'm saying past pawns even
though it's hard to imagine any past
pawns uh you know being
made here uh but that's why it's such a
nice game so queen d8 and now comes the
the idea dude i had so you could maybe
trade off a pair of rooks first but he
decides to keep them on the board and
plays knight b captures an a5 so it's a
knight for two pawns but you are getting
a past a pawn and it's a white
definitely white who's pushing for a win
here b captures knight captures on a5
and now rook to h2 putting pressure on
the g2 pawn but also if white is ever to
capture the rook here then this pawn
becomes incredibly strong so that's
maybe
why it could be a little a bit of an
improvement if you traded rooks with
rook captures on h8 before going for
this knight captures on a5 sacrifice
so here we have knight to b7 now you are
ready to push the a pawn and we have
queen to c8
uh
just uh you know getting the the the
queen closer to the action we have a5
and now rook captures on b7 so black
it's a blitz game you don't have time to
figure out anything you had to do
something to stop at least some of those
pawns so here we have captures captures
king the b4 now you know why duda
brought his king all the way to c3 he
saw this position and he knows that the
king will be uh very much needed here to
help out
in the support of the pawn so here at
knight to 87 rook h to c1 now an
incredibly strong move as now you have
the queen guarding the g2 pawn and also
you are completely controlling the c
file so no c5 uh tricky ideas can can be
possible here we have queen to a7 trying
to maybe uh do some damage with queen to
d4 check but not a problem rook to a2
and now if even if queen to d4 you can
simply block with queen to c4 because
the rook is now guarding the g2 pawn so
instead dimchenko goes knight to g6 we
have queen to c4 now putting pressure on
this pawn and there's no real way of
defending this pawn so you have to give
it up queen the e3 was played but now
just a6 dude says i can always capture
this pawn black is without a single move
so he has to do something queen to a7
now do the traits queen captures in c7
queen to d4 check now queen back to c4
uh and now queen back to a7 so black is
still hoping to hold this off somehow uh
but um you know the these two pawns are
incredibly strong i i i you know i have
a feeling that uh duda would do this
even if this was a classical game so uh
playing it in blitz makes it all the
more appealing because it's incredibly
difficult to defend this with a little
time on the clock so instead so uh king
to a5 now preparing b6 you can see that
the king is really a valuable member of
this attack queen back to e3 and now we
have b6 we have knight to h4 black now
also is trying to create some sort of a
pass pawn to counter those pawns but a7
we have knight characters on f3 asking
now
to capture the knight but the dude
ignores it he just brings a queen into
the game now comes knight to d4 and yes
white has two queens and two rooks but
the king is on a5 the knight is here the
queen is here so maybe you know yeah if
everything works out perfectly for black
maybe you could uh
organize some sort of an attack here but
very unlikely duda doesn't uh think it's
possible so he just pushes b7 he wants
another queen on the board with f3 and
now b8 queen here we have f captures on
g2 black also ready to promote his spawn
maybe
but now with four queens on the board uh
it's really only only a matter of which
checkmate in seven do you choose duda
goes for rook to g8 to check king to f6
and here he plays queen eight to f8 and
he was in this position on move 56 that
anton nimchenko resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
there are many many checkmates lurking
in the position but the the simplest one
is just well let's say queen to g7 and
it's uh game over so uh there's really
no no defending this or if you try
something like queen captures an e4 then
queen captures an f7 is also a nice
checkmate uh there there's no way to
avoid it so of course he resigned and
what a wonderful game with four queens
on the board but not just four queens
there are also three rooks and the night
and wow it's just a completely crazy
position not something that you would
see in in a classical or even a rapid
game
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh very big congratulations
to duda
on achieving this uh beautiful game and
also on leading the the
european uh blitz championship uh i
would just like to mention that uh i'm
organizing uh pre-christmas uh uh
leeches arena and we're gonna have some
very nice prizes for the arena so i'm
interested uh what do you guys enjoy
watching most it the the prices will be
very very handsome so i'm expecting a
lot of strong players to to play in the
arena so what time format would you guys
enjoy seeing the most what would be you
know
i don't know i'm open to suggestions do
share your thoughts in the comments
below i'm going to go through all of
them we have some ideas of what we what
we want to have but you know i'm still
open to suggestions
and
for the moment it's going to be on 21st
of december
so but more more information probably in
the video tomorrow uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it i would
like to thank happy birthday george uh
happy birthday bill koska uh mathias
lock uh cameron alice enterprises and
kim doleman for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of well
everything else that's happening in the
chess world and as usual checking up on
your wonderful suggestions uh thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day